oh my God imagine how much that would
hurt that would be crazy especially it's
like really famous you can't even get
used to that it's always going to be
offputting
butthole not that
[Music]
bad what in your guys's Minds would be
torture if you were forced to listen to
some music what's torture for you I love
a lot of music do you yes it just
depends on the Move okay I feel like you
could always find something to like in
any genre but like country sometimes I'm
just like you don't like country some
country some country probably like
female Liverpool rap wait what's that
what that Liverpool rap how did she even
come across I just thought about
something I would hate he and it would
be that wa dude I don't know UK drill
and [__] was like it's it's kind of cool
that's what I imagine Liverpool rap to
be but SCA 2 plus 2 is four female SCA
that's true
I like that s what about you Mark I was
thinking yeah but I'm kind of like Joe
like I think I like all music and I
could find something enjoyable about
what about country music I'll tell you
something I'll tell you something I I
took a class called music appreciation
right and then the teacher asked us this
question the professor was like what is
your music what kind of music you like
and then we're just like oh you know
what I like this but I don't like metal
and then this other kid was like man I
[__] hate country and then he goes
how can you hate a a genre it's like
saying you hate a language and I'm like
wait what and he goes you can only not
understand or understand music there is
no love and hate and I was like that's
that's probably true though do you like
do you like
Drake M you like stream [__] like Drake
[__] I listen to it but it's not my
preference and I think cuz I don't know
how to vibe to that means you hate it I
don't hate it kid some Drake songs I
can't I can't stand I can't get into any
I can't some of them I'm just like dude
I'm but the Beats cuz you know what it
is though he has really dope beats so
it's kind of like some of the stuff he's
talking about I'm like this is a
different world I don't understand it
but like it's catchy though and then if
it's on you know radio or like
mainstream playlist or whatever it's
there you know what I don't like you
don't like comedy in comedy the the term
is blue right when they're just kind of
hacking just saying sexual [__] I don't
like like blue rap like shot comedy like
some rap it's just like [__] [__]
[__] py I love [__] pyet [__] [__]
everywhere and I'm just like I get that
I'm like there's like more metaphorical
or creative ways of getting the same
thing across but when it's just so on
the nose I don't really like that one
you can't listen to it all the time yeah
that's how I feel let me hear two lip
wet two lip not wet ass [__] yeah it's
just constantly just [__] [__] just
dripping dripping moisture like that
like that one Drake song with sexy red
goes hands on your knees hands and she
says let your coochie breathe I like
that song unpopular opinion I like that
song a lot unpopular opinion I don't
like Kanye I don't like really I don't
listen to any I think the more he's
evolved in his way the less I like them
oh I agree I think earlier Kan was
better yeah no bro new Kan is [__]
dud I think the the genre of music I
listen to the least is mainstream
hip-hop and pop oh but I I listen to Old
School poop and I listen to like older
genres like Funk and old SCH me too and
then I bounc around with like K-pop
J-pop like Japanese music uh Spanish
music like I jump all over oh I I
actually love K-pop I don't understand
what's happening I don't listen to it on
my own but when I hear it I feel like a
better human being I don't really like
oh I like K-pop like I feel like I'm put
together now like I want to go to work
and put on a suit and tie and [__] hey
you ever listen to like like Japanese
Jazz bro it's sick oh yeah that [__] is
tight dude I'll put you on his [__]
lady what's their [__] name I love
their like oh that one all you try to
put us on to her I'm going to tell you a
story about one of the strictest prisons
in Russia oh no it's a form of oh so
they have a playlist of songs they play
to inmates every morning over
loudspeakers in order to torture them
the playlist includes multiple bonjovi
songs shut the [__] up I didn't expect
that but what about Micki matubara I
don't know who that I know who that is
yeah stay with me Yep this stay oh
you're talking about City pop yeah
Japanese City pop
yeah that's going to that's kind of cool
yeah careful careful careful sorry
making I love that [__] wait so by Bon
jobi is this like new bonji music cuz
that would be tortur it's like Living on
a Prayer
oh song but for Russians they hate it
but if you keep overplaying I think if
you overplay anything it becomes like a
hell dude it's like I don't want to hear
this anymore it's a classic any song
that's on repeat 40 times I think will
[__] you like baby sharp didn't they use
that as a torture baby shark sounds more
baby shark kids love it yeah but baby
shark worked on me the first time I
heard it like I hated it what else do
they play in this prison okay so they
play
Moby oh which one though it's like a lot
of techno right that's like [__] cuz
it's like monotonous it's like some but
haven't you guys liked the song so much
that you're like Play it Again Play it
again by Mo not Mo not a thousand times
yeah too much Moi does make you feel a
little funny dude any mo I'm not into
but just out of spite if I was an inmate
I'd be so petty to the point where I'm
like no I'm going to you trying to do
this to make me hate it I'm going to be
a fan of it so every day I enjoy these
songs [__] give me Bono come on dude
let's let's go you two let's do man
Bring it on I have a friend who was
trying to brag to me that um she was
dating Moi but then the more that she
was telling me the story about about how
she would go to his house and they would
have sex and then she would leave I was
like yeah you're pretty much just
[__] Obi and then he's like telling
you to go home y it's sucks to that guy
you're kind of you're kind of a sex
object here just so you know he's not
buying you flowers and taking you out
any anywhere doesn't want people to see
how is it dating you guys talking or no
any restaurants harsh truths no what
else they play in there okay they play
acdc's thunder struck oh that's dope I
play that struck dude some of these AR I
was expecting worse right maybe to
Russian ears it's just really bad the
only torture here is they can't rock out
in a 3X3 cell you know oh yeah yeah yeah
you can't thrash the way you want to
that's the real torture just STI your
arms past the bars oh yeah that's true
they also play the Russian national
anthem not necessarily for torture but
they play it as well for brainwash to
break it up maybe and then they sing
songs about
Moscow oh if it's jingus Khan Moscow
that's an amazing song is it yeah I
wonder if foreign criminals come to
America and go you know what it's not so
bad cuz it could be the goag yeah it
could be the jails
overseas why why are the Russian prisons
so [__] Infamous do you guys know the
Gog I oh it's like Mexican prison too
it's like I think every prison American
no American prisons are notorious for
like rape stuff yeah American prisons
are also not nice I think I think other
prisons you're scared of the guards I
think our prisons you're scared of other
prisoners yeah cuz they can get attack
your boot or you're scared of the
ecosystem that you you're not familiar
with and you just get dropped in yeah
that's crazy have you guys heard It's My
Life by V jobi it's my
life I think on repeat I
could I I kill myself with over and over
or if you're like trying to go to sleep
and they're just bumping the same song
40 times oh my god oh that's just
annoying oh you're sleep deprived over a
couple weeks bro that's tough dude I got
a neighbor who has they just decorated
for Christmas right and they have this
[__] Nutcracker that stands like it's
like a big boy it's like his big as like
can that's bigger two times can and then
um it plays this
like oh no but in Las Vegas we have wind
and so yeah it has the sensor gets
tripped every [__] other second and
so I'm trying to sleep the other night
and this thing's just going D
and I'm the only [__] in the
whole neighborhood who could hear it I
swear cuz nobody's no one hears it
nobody could hear but me I was the only
one and I just even Nikki she didn't
even say nothing Nikki was on the other
side of the house cuz I was snoring so
she was like you have to [__] get out
of here you're snoring too much and I
was like okay so then I go to the guest
room and the guest room's facing the
street so then I'm
hearing I do love that song you know
what about all I want for Christmas
you're not tired of that song dude
that's like the most annoying song I
feel like every it's not Christmas
unless you hear
in that song into my ears I'm so annoyed
cuz I don't hear it any other time of
the year so when it comes during
Christmas it's perfect kind of a like I
hear it all the
time throughout the year no like yeah so
no for me you're supposed to binge on it
during December that's when you do it
but because you binging in December it
feels like I'm hearing it all year good
bro if I hear Josh groin silent night
I'll put a bullet in my brain at that J
oh Josh grin's torture for me man you
know what you know what be the ultimate
torture
to play all these songs in the prison
but you take the instrumental the
acapella you extract it and then you
move the Acappella half a count
forward oh that's you're a
monster that's like scratching the
chalkboard dude so that not even never
matches oh my God imagine how much that
would hurt that would be crazy
especially it's like really famous cuz
you can't even get used to that it's
always going to be offputting with your
butthole not that bad
I don't like that John lennen song So
This Is Christmas so this is Christmas
oh dude remember that one that we were
talking about the one that [__] is in
Bruce Springsteen holidays are coming
oh it just starts cracking up in the
middle of the track yeah dude he says it
so many times he's basically just like
pay me you dumb [__] pay me exactly
yeah it's such a low effort thing yeah
when are you guys going to make a
Christmas album a whole album you have a
Christmas song dude that shit's going to
blow up man if you guys made a Christmas
song Christmas people want a a JK
calendar after they saw us doing a photo
shoot see that's so funny dude there you
go ideas I'd be so down to make a
Christmas album I would just like it'd
be like like Ray gay
Rudolph re Rudolph dude steel drums
Rudolph the red no reindeer
Jam that'll be so tight get canceled
immediately like dubstep [__]
Bethlehem or something every track every
track is a different genre yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah Silver
Bells Silver Bell [__] crazy you guys
like listening to
like do you oh I don't I don't really
like that kind of stuff no but we could
get Alex to do that for us I like
wearing their shirts though cuz they're
sick shirts shirts dude metal shirts are
the best the [__] best man but the
music sucks I know it does yeah I can't
I can't listen to it for that long one
of my buddies went to a viking music
concert oh Viking music Viking Viking
like Icelandic metal yeah bro and it it
it's actually kind of fire but it's like
a lot of like like a lot of like it
sounds like yeah yeah yeah kind it's
kind of like that bro like throat
singing type stuff
yeah like that I like gu though gu is
hilarious gu is cool cuz they like they
have like giant like fake dicks and like
they cut off like George Bush's head
like whoever's president doesn't matter
who it is they cut off their head like
paper big paper head they cut it off and
then like they come on the crowd with
like fake C and stuff I just like them
because be is in but cuz they like them
they just like love Gore oh love it yeah
Gore's great so is Ramstein I don't know
what you guys are saying that's that
techn Viking [__] too yeah yeah yeah oh
you know what else would be torture
Happy Hardcore oh that's hard to listen
to for a long
time what about Taylor Swift you got
swifties I like T I love Taylor Swift
You listen to a whole Taylor Swift album
and there's enough variety that you
actually want I sound like I'm selling
it yeah you do sounds like you're all
Taylor Swift shs
dude Silver
[Music]
Bells